منذ القرن التاسع عشر اكثر من 130 سنه لم
يدلي اي فرد من العائله الملكيه
البريطانيه بشهاده امام المحكمه اخر من
فعل ذلك كان ادوارد السابع لكن الطريق
تغير على يد الامير هاري والسبب مقاضاته
لمجموعه ميرير الصحفيه الامير هاري يتهم
المجموعه بانها اخترقت هاتفه واستخدمت
وسائل اخرى غير قانونيه لجمع معلومات عن
حياته بين عامي 1996 و9 بعض المحررين
الصحفيين تلطخت ايديهم بالدماء ربما هو
موت من غير قصد كانت هذه بعض كلمات هاري
امام المحكمه يقصد هاري طبعا ما نشرته
الصحافه عن والدته الاميره ديانا امر لا
يريد هاري ان يتكرر مع اطفاله
لقد كانت والدتي وحيده تحاول ان ترعى
طفليها مع كل هذه المضايقات الاعلاميه
الشديده كانت تطارد معظم حياتها عندما
كانت مع والدي ومتى الامر اسوا عندما تم
الطلاق لذلك فانا افعل كلما في وسعيد
للتاكد من عدم حدوث ذلك لعائلتي وساستمر
في ذلك لانه بالتاكيد لا يبدو ان الصحافه
البريطانيه قد غيرت طرقها
هاري ليس وحده نحن 100 من المشاهير يقادون
المجموعه الصحفيه التي اعتبرت بالفعل
لهاري واكدت انه يحق له الحصول على
تعويضنا مناسب ورغم الاعتذار تصر الشركه
المالكه لمجموعه ملر الصحفيه انه لا لو
على المديرين التنفيذيين لان هذا النشاط
غير القانوني اخفي بشكل مقصود من قبل
الصحفيين لكن ما يمكن ان يضحك هذه الفرضيه
ان احد الادعاءات الرئيسيه في القضيه هو
ان مقدم البرامج التلفزيونيه
والذي تراس تحرير المرر منذ عام 1995 وحتى
2004 كان على علم بهذا النشاط غير
القانوني مورجن من ناحيته نفى مرارا
التورط في الاختراقات غير القانونيه فهل
يمكن ان يقدم اعتذاره نهائي
اتلقى محاضراتنا عن انتهاك الخصوصيه من
الامير هاري هو شخص قضاء اخر ثلاث سنوات
بسخريه وبلا رحمه في انتهاك خصوصيه
العائله المالكه من اجل لعبه تجاريه واسعه
وعبر مجموعه من الاكاذيب التي قالها لذلك
انا اقترح عليه ان يخرج من المحكمه وان
يعتذر لعائلته عن انتهاكه المشير للخصوصي
هي اللحظه التي انتظرها الامير هاري منذ
سنوات محاسبه الاعلام على ما يقول انها
معاناه تسبب بها ليس بحقه فقط وانما بحق
والدته الراحل الاميره ديانا وبحق مقربين
منه ايضا محاكمه هذا الاسبوع ضد مجموعه
صحف مر هي واحده من بين ثلاث محاكمات
يخوضها هذه ضد صحافه التاب يستند في
ادعاءاته الى مقالات اخباريه يقول انه
يريد معرفه كيفيه جمع معلوماتها ويتهم
الصحف باستخدام طرق غير قانونيه في الحصول
عليها
33 مقاله سئل عنها بادق التفاصيل في جلستك
محاكمه استمرت اكثر من ثمان ساعات خلال
يومين محامي الدفاع انجبرين سال هاري اكثر
من مره هل مزاعمه تستند الى تكهنات ام
انها تستند الى ادله متوفره ما يعني ان
توفر الادله هو الذي سيحسم القضيه لصالح
احد الطرفين هذه بدا متوترا في البدايه
لكنه اصبح اكثر هدوءا مع مرور الوقت واكثر
جراه في ردوده في اليوم الثاني قد يفوز
هذه بالراي العام لكن سيحتاج اكثر من
مشاعر التعاطف لاقناع القاضي باساءه
الصحافه له
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات